[Música]
con un multitudinario desfile militar
rusia conmemora el aniversario 77 del
día de la victoria fecha en la que se
celebra la derrota de la alemania nazi
durante la segunda guerra mundial el
kremlin justificó su invasión a ucrania
el canciller alemán olaf scholz recibió
en berlín al presidente francés emmanuel
manjón los líderes pidieron un cese el
fuego en ucrania para poder impulsar las
negociaciones de paz mientras que el
terreno los ataques no cesan tenemos
información desde la región del donbass
en ecuador cerca de 50 personas
perdieron la vida en medio de nuevos
enfrentamientos registrados en la cárcel
de la provincia de santo domingo de los
tsáchilas lo que eleva más de 60 el
número de reos asesinados en
amotinamientos en instituciones
penitenciarias este año
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas fue
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en moscú la
capital rusa donde el lunes se conmemoró
el aniversario número 77 del día de la
victoria con un tradicional desfile
militar el 9 de mayo marca la derrota de
la alemania nazi durante la segunda
guerra mundial
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
aprovechó la ocasión para justificar su
invasión a ucrania
los ataques no se están en la ciudad
ucraniana de mariupol fuentes de la
alcaldía señalaron que tras finalizar la
evacuación de civiles de la planta das
hostal las tropas rusas destruyeron un
puente que servía para las evacuaciones
para evitar que los soldados ucranianos
abandonen la instalación entretanto en
el este en la región del donbass se ha
intensificado la guerra que ya se vivía
en esta región desde hace ocho años las
agresiones han alcanzado decenas de
civiles cuyas casas van quedando
destruidas
a medida que los ataques con artillería
y bombardeos se hacen mayores nuestros
enviados especiales catalina gómez ángel
y mikel con nate nos muestran la
realidad de lo que se vive en esa zona
la familia se reunió en torno a la tacha
para ayudarle a limpiar lo que queda de
su casa
hasta el triple ataque de la madrugada
del 7 de mayo ella habitaba esta
vivienda junto con sus cuatro hijos uno
de ellos con problemas de movilidad
dice que ahora no están aquí los ha
dejado en la casa de su abuela todos
están a salvo porque huyeron después del
primer impacto
la casa la hicimos con un préstamo hemos
pagado parte y todavía tenemos que pagar
el resto esta es una de las 25 viviendas
destruidas en una población a 10
kilómetros de crematorios donde
alrededor de 45 mil habitantes han
decidido permanecer en la ciudad
al comienzo a la invasión se temió que
el avance ruso llegaría de inmediato en
esta región del donbass en el este de
ucrania
pero pasaron semanas antes de que la
ofensiva se intensificará las provincias
de donde sin lugares donde la guerra se
prolonga desde 2014 alimentada por moscú
no nos pasará lo mismo que mariupol y
estamos protegidos por el paisaje el río
hemos tenido suficiente tiempo durante
los últimos 72 días para prepararnos
esta es la vida que conduce hasta el isi
shanks en la región de lugansk
toda esta zona está militarizada y los
ataques son continuos
los rusos intentan destruir esta
refinería y en las últimas horas han
logrado controlar algunas poblaciones
cercanas
la situación en jacob lip k es diferente
a otros de la región aquí sus habitantes
mayoritariamente campesinos intentan
continuar su vida como oksana y su hija
lisa
estamos muy preocupados porque ellos
están acercando cada día más sueño de
vuelta en crematorio olga busca los
objetos que se pudieron salvar de lo que
fue su casa
la explosión cayó a pocos metros de la
entrada
y sentimos algo cerca me levanté y abrir
todas las ventanas ellos dijeron que es
mejor para la onda expansiva luego llegó
silencio oiga cuenta que se salvó porque
decido entrar en ese momento al baño
protegido por una doble pared ocho años
han pasado desde que esta región quedará
sumergida en la guerra pero sus
habitantes reconocen que los ataques
actuales han puesto su vida al límite
como nunca antes
el presidente francés emmanuel mccomb
viajó a berlín en su primera salida
internacional tras su reelección como
presidente allí lo recibió el canciller
alemán olaf scholz se hablaron
principalmente del conflicto en ucrania
al respecto pidieron un cese del fuego
para poder impulsar las negociaciones de
paz otro tema central fue el futuro de
la unión europea marco propuso la
creación de un club europeo que vaya más
allá de los 27 miembros con aquellos
países del viejo continente que
compartan valores con el fin de crear
una europa más fuerte
en el día de europa el reelegido
presidente francés emmanuel macrón dijo
que no es realista que ucrania se
incorpore en un futuro próximo al bloque
europeo ya que los 27 miembros se han
mostrado unidos en el respaldo aquí el
macro propone ahora un nuevo mecanismo
de cooperación
pero aunque mañana le diéramos el
estatus de país candidato el proceso se
ha iniciado y espero que avancemos
rápidamente hacia la adhesión pero todos
sabemos muy bien que el proceso de
adhesión llevaría varios años de hecho
probablemente varias décadas la edición
después de su discurso en estrasburgo
ante el parlamento europeo el mandatario
se trasladó a berlín alemania en la
primera visita oficial de su nuevo
mandato allí fue recibido por el
canciller alemán olaf scholz a quien
reiteró su propuesta de crear lo que
denominó una comunidad política europea
abierta a todos los países que no se han
adherido al bloque pero que comparten
los mismos valores
como ya es también quizás una manera de
encontrar estabilidad y otra forma de
cooperación con países como reino unido
ha decidido abandonar nuestra unión
europea pero que puede tener su lugar en
esta comunidad política a 23 sep las 12
minutos el canciller alemán calificó de
interesante la idea añadiendo que debe
combinarse con las negociaciones de
ingresos de algunos países bálticos mons
los artistas me gustaría decir
expresamente que se trata de una
propuesta muy interesante para el gran
reto al que nos enfrentamos estamos
llevando adelante el proceso de
integración permanente de la unión
europea ambos queremos una unión europea
fuerte y soberana
en este sentido ambos anunciaron que en
junio se llevará a cabo una cumbre de
los balcanes occidentales para avanzar
en la adhesión de más países a la unión
europea los políticos pidieron también
el test del fuego en ucrania
en ecuador cerca de 50 fallecidos y más
de un centenar de presos fugitivos dejó
un motín registrado en la cárcel
bellavista de la ciudad de santo domingo
de acuerdo con las autoridades de ese
país suramericano la mayoría de las
víctimas fueron atacadas con arma blanca
la crisis carcelaria que arrastra
ecuador se ha cobrado la vida de al
menos 400 personas en un periodo de dos
años y es todo un desafío para el
presidente guillermo lasso con pablo lo
cómico en el informe
un nuevo episodio de violencia en una
cárcel de ecuador banda de rivales de la
prisión de bellavista se enfrentaron en
la provincia de santo domingo y aunque
las autoridades lograron recuperar el
control en horas de la tarde aseguraron
que todavía hay prófugos la mayoría de
ellos por no decir casi el 100% a simple
vista se puede observar fueron privados
de la vida con arma blanca no fue un
arma de fuego y la mayoría de cuerpos
fueron expuestos
agredidos en los pabellones y en las
celdas
la violencia dentro de las cárceles es
un problema al que se enfrenta al
gobierno del presidente guillermo lasso
desde por lo menos hace un año según
informes del ministerio de defensa tan
solo desde febrero de 2021 han muerto
350 reclusos en el ecuador un país que
alberga a 35 mil personas en prisiones
que superan hasta el 15 por ciento de su
capacidad máxima según la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos los
motines carcelarios se deben al abandono
estatal el hacinamiento y la ausencia de
una política integral
con las manos
el gobierno ecuatoriano ha asegurado que
el incremento de la violencia está
directamente ligado al narcotráfico en
la zona
un vecino de colombia y perú los mayores
productores de cocaína en el mundo
ecuador ha servido como puerto de salida
de cargamentos hacia eeuu y europa en
2021 el gobierno de lazo incautó una
cifra récord de 210 toneladas de droga
en lo que va de 2022 ya se han incautado
70 toneladas de estupefacientes y
finalizamos en nueva york donde una obra
del artista andy warhol rompió el récord
como la pieza más cara del siglo 20
vendida en una subasta pública estamos
hablando del shot 6 view marilyn
subastada por la casa christie's en 195
millones de dólares se desconoce la
identidad del comprador mientras que el
vendedor fue la fundación son más and
there is a man creada por uno de los
mayores magnates de arte contemporáneo y
amigo de andy warhol la institución
prometido destinar el importe de la
venta a proyectos sociales
es todo por el momento en france 24 les
agradecemos su sintonía
[Música]